souviens toi
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
attention tu vas bientôt le même
problème que tu ne bougez pas je suis à
d un ex beau gosse na na nana na na tu
vas avoir des problèmes de julian bugier
je te le dis m'attendais à me faire
chier pas mon bébé ça va une fois n'est
pas coutume gilles verdez encore craqué
savage il ya encore traiter quelqu'un
d'islamophobe oui donc tout de suite le
poids fâchons pas facho chupa fashion
show donc gilles après avoir traité une
bouteille d'eau d'islam ont fait la
semaine dernière tu as dû payer 5000
euros pour des frais de justice parce
que tu as traité bernard de la
villardière d'islamophobe et en plus
hier soir tu nous annonce au calme que
c'est la prod qui a payé
il a attaqué que moi j'ai été le seul à
être condamné et qu'on perd des nerfs et
donc il y avait en tout ou à peu près
avec les frais de justice était autour
de 5000 euros avait quand même donc je
m'apprêtais à faire un chèque camp et je
tiens à vous rendre hommage il faut que
les téléspectateurs le sas quand vous et
lionel stan qui dirige général dale
toyne h2o m'ont dit ben on s'est tu as
été condamné en pondant propre mais
c'était pendant l'émission donc tu ne
payent rien voilà lionel syne donc c'est
à cause de gilles que depuis une semaine
on n'a plus à manger dans les loges
j'ai vu deux techniciens se bat pour un
tweak ses chers téléspectateurs
pouvaient commander le livre de gilles
verdez regarder ce livre comment j'ai
ruiné ma preuve aux éditions flammarion
maréchal
[Applaudissements]
oui j'ai je te le dis avec sympathie
t comme les convertis tu en fais trop il
est plus engagé que les musulmans sur la
cause musulmane
je sais que tu aimes fatou mais calme
toi sinon elle va te retrouver en prison
donc maintenant la vraie question oui
cyril hier vous avez réussi à parler de
cette vidéo qui a fait le besoin l'homme
pousse une femme dans un escalier du
métro
là on est contre la ministe de tik tok
instagram marlène schiappa a aussitôt
pris position parce qu'elle aime pas les
rouleaux c'est donc l'heure
coucou les relous du coucou coucou
coucou coucou les relous salue
aujourd'hui dans coucou les relous c'est
pas bien pousser une femme dans un
escalier
ça se fait pas c'est relou mais là c'est
une embrouille de crackers et bah voilà
c'est pas le gâteau en plus lol on
parlera d'un autre relou hakim qui a
vendu de labeur christophe et christophe
qui a découvert que c'était des herbes
de provence trop relou coucou coucou
coucou coucou les relous la polémique
d'hier était sur l'un des chroniqueurs
guillaume genton linéarité et je vous
demande de l'applaudir qui a donné son
jogging qui a été coloriée par des
enfants de maternelle
lire
c'est un peu notre karl lagerfeld
toujours élégant mais visiblement
l'élégance n'est pas la qualité des
influenceurs sur lesquels tu faisais un
documentaire regarder ce mardi soir nous
terminons tournage à 20 heures les
équipes rentrent chez elles
je suis chez moi évidemment c'est après
l'émission où j'étais là jusqu'à 21h20
je rentre chez moi et il se trouve que
les influenceurs qui je le rappelle sont
majeurs et ont un manager qui lui aussi
est majeur ont organisé une soirée
clandestine de combien de personnes de
50 personnes
me guillaume guillaume tu fais confiance
à des tic toc heures à mais faut pas
faire ça est-ce qu'on fait confiance à
des gens qui font ça regardes et tu leur
fais confiance là tu vois pas qui a rien
à tirer de cette génération j'en ai deux
mois dans la presse la presse s'est
déchaînée sur toi mais heureusement tpm
paix c'est une famille ciel tu m'as dit
là bas tout le monde tout le monde ce n
est quand on a posé la question
chroniqueur si tu étais coupable regarde
et vois la pression colonnes à des
chroniqueurs comme ça qu'a pas besoin
d'ennemis
moment il t'a traiter d'islamophobe
d'ailleurs je sais pas si t'es au
courant mais les chroniqueurs ont voté
oui avec d'autres questions regarder
faut t-il éxécuté guillaume chante par
guillotine en direct jeudi prochain tp
oui à l'unanimité donc je récapitule la
sphère guillaume genton film des tic toc
heures qui ensuite organise une fête
avec 50 personnes en période de
confinement dans une maison qui est
mitoyenne à celle de nicolas sarkozy
alors si francis veber chercher un
scénario pour la suite de la chaîne
alors la folie en plus c'est que c'est
sarkozy lui même qui est venu sonner à
la porte je suis sûr que les tic toc
heures ils ont ouvert ils l'ont même pas
reconnu israël s'intéresse par la police
lundi
un à la une est relou vient on appelle
marlène schiappa
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]